but there was some darkness at the club
too and rarely do I perform and I'm
caught off guard rarely does where I'm
speechless almost and I don't know what
to do by heckler so first show Saturday
night's going pretty good and all of a
sudden I feel a presence on stage and I
look over and there is a white woman on
stage and she hands me a phone okay so
she goes
so what's calling you that's what she
says number one I think she works for
the club
yeah and number two kalila didn't come
with me she was gonna come later she was
in Portland with me she's gonna come
later right so the first thought is oh
my God look you know oh I didn't know
she had already been at the club but I
was on stage when she'd arrived yeah so
my first thought is what the [ __ ]
something happened a tote oh you know so
I pick it up hello hello and it doesn't
work the phone and then I look down on
it and it's not even a phone that anyone
would use it's like an 80s gigantic
phone that you probably reach people
would have in their car it's like a Zac
from Saved by the Bell big one a huge
one which makes me let me feel even more
[ __ ] liked it up which makes me feel
and then she says no no it's the 80s
they're calling to get your act back
their act back like my act was yeah from
the 80s or something which makes no
sense enough I mean but being sensitive
I'm thinking this is Portland Ron
Funches it from here you mean maybe this
is like I'm - maybe I'm like the Mort
Sahl of you know man Portland so I go
what she doesn't know I mean is it a
funny that's also Jesus so I give her
the phone back I go leave and then I
didn't and the room was sold out I
couldn't continue
I didn't you couldn't continue because
you were frightened that something had
happened you already had it in your head
that something had happened to me or
your parents yeah so you were in in
shock that's why you didn't have a good
retort what regardless of what it was I
didn't have one so then what I did was
and this used to you I used to use this
years back and sometimes it works that
sometimes you say I'm gonna start over
so I bring sandy back on stage like
right as a bit right and then Sandy
brings me back up again and I just
started from my act from the beginning
right no it didn't work this time
because the other thing was so awkward
and weird that they were just kind they
were all frightened almost like this is
weird [ __ ] so that that didn't work and
then I just and then the worst thing is
I go that fat [ __ ] over a lot that
because she was really fast and a crowd
turned on me how are they [ __ ]
interrupted your set their show right so
they were like oh and I go you [ __ ]
betrayers I screamed at them which then
usually makes them laugh didn't laugh
what the [ __ ] is this cry so now I'm in
a situation where I mean like or orange
what in the country when it's like their
terrorist level what's the red alert or
orange is pretty high up yeah I'm an
orange alert okay so then I go I'm just
gonna get naked that's like five minutes
that's my go-to every time so yeah yeah
like I'm gonna get naked like remember
that movie Red Dawn like if Russia
attacked or whatever right and I was
captured out so I would do it just get
completely naked it's a coping mechanism
mechanism defense mechanism and also
they may be like it they won't kill me
and they'll just leave me as it use me
as a court jester yeah you mean that's
my there's a gesture gesture right
that's my go-to I want to be the court
jester yeah so I did that and then it
was weird
we got kinda got a laugh at the end I
got backstage and then I was in a red
zone and I feel
so bad but when I'm in a red zone I just
start [ __ ] mouthing off
were you there I was already there yeah
and then I get to manager and then I say
all kinds of stuff like I'm never gonna
play her again I'm gonna call mark the
owner I mean all kinds of stuff which to
them is the worst thing that anyone can
say they just start panicking mm-hmm
which I'm not gonna do any of that
really in real life but you think then
that there should always be someone on
guard watching the show who takes care
of a heckler who walks up on stage
because to be a performer yeah does not
even security but but you know someone
who can
you know delegate a room a little bit
better you know when you see a woman
walk on stage when a contraption that to
me is the look that I would be under
defense you know - I'd get the [ __ ] out
of your [ __ ] like I don't know you
could give her in my space you know also
I know certain performer she was crying
outside yeah and then what yeah flying
outside saying oh my god no right you
gotta be kidding me right now no I'm not
kidding you
yeah so not only that she [ __ ] up my
show right blames it on you she blames
it on me yeah and then she said she's
accusing me of calling her fat which I
did and I apologize yeah but she you
know God I'm sorry for calling you fat
but let me tell you something that I if
you didn't come up on stage I wouldn't
even know who you were and I would never
called you fat you know lesson good
lesson learned for her though you can't
heckle like that on a show this isn't an
interactive experience it's not only
that and the stand-up is the only live
entertainment like show right where they
just stuff like that happens and no one
gives a [ __ ] like if that happened if
you're watching wicked on Broadway
the green witches on stage sing a little
tune that right important walks up with
a [ __ ] phone what do you think that
would happen what would get tackled and
dragged by yes and that's what I wanted
but that didn't happen
clubs don't do that they don't do that
in fact they don't no one gets in
trouble she didn't get in trouble
like if somebody walk
got on wicked and Broadway oh they would
get arrested Oh yet cops honest Oh
honestly right but they didn't happen
that's and that's also too far I'm fine
okay but but my concern is this is that
I always yell because someone like Brian
Regan who is one point one of the best
comics in the country mm-hmm and I know
the guy he doesn't like dealing with
audience in that way he doesn't he does
his act if people yell it out he doesn't
especially in the early days never
really acknowledged it he just kept
going and that's what it's supposed to
be because of all these be rooms see
what happened in the 90s was comedy
became a it was a boom in the early 90s
late eighties early nineties you could
turn on the TV well first of all in the
80s if he gave it such a thing that
every town had five or six comedy clubs
you could make millions of dollars
damn but what that did was it made you
know your next-door neighbor want to do
it so then you had a bunch of people
that shouldn't be doing it in the
[ __ ] first place doing it and then
all of a sudden you know in the 90s it
died but because you had such bad comics
doing it the audience's right they
didn't know how to behave so when you
when a B room is really awful for what's
a beer explain to everyone a be room is
B rooms aren't bad I've done them before
I used to do them all the time but
basically there are clubs that have more
Road comics so a road comic is somebody
that really ins never been on TV there
they just kind of do the road from gig
to gig and their jokes are generally
about airplanes driving things that are
like observation mean potatoes
observational but a lot of them also are
very dirty you know and they also like
riffing with the crowd they go in and
you know it's combative sometimes some
of them have catchphrases like shucky
ducky you know that is there was a comic
named shucky ducky Road comic and he
would tell a joke and in between the
jokes he would go
ducky quack quack right but the crowd
would go shucky ducky quack quack with
him right and he would sell out because
it was a bunch of its African Americans
loved him interactive yeah you know I
mean it shucky ducky quack laughs baby
baby shut the gag chuckle duckies
company I'm not saying I'm is that a bad
accident but you know I'm saying yeah
there's another one in hamburger because
hamburger and the whole audience goes
hamburger and they giggle people like
this yeah they love it they said they
sell out but because of that you mean
you go onstage and they go poop time say
it catchphrase Rock Honka me do it do it
no if you find yourself playing cook
time yeah and everyone's a good time
right and because audiences are
conditioned to do that but like an a
room has guys like Kevin Nealon guys
that have been on television tonight
she'll have reps they have you know it's
an a-list a room I mean I do I fit that
sad to say no because that's a real
thing I be rooms exist those are called
be room yeah they're called it in the
comedy community that's what they're
called it's not the actual room it's
more the people on the lineup what the
problem was and they don't pay their
performers a lot of money a lot of pay
them a hundred dollars a show the
headline [ __ ] and the performers have to
pay for their own food they're not
taking care of really all that rule that
they're not put up right you find your
way here you know maybe you'd get in a
call rooms are different we'll pick you
up from the airport we'll pay you this
amount slight note I'll tell everything
it's like if you press they treat their
performers you get a percentage of the
door you know it's just the way it
should be because it's the hardest thing
one can do and if you can do it I'm not
saying that I'm talented I'm just saying
that I've been doing it for 20 years and
it's like you know if I'm gonna do it I
want to make money I want to make money
and Harvey's was a club in Portland for
30 years
there was a be room helium wasn't there
the place I played
and what happens is if you only have one
comedy club in a city and it's a be room
that's what they're used to
to the people the audience is
conditioned to be rallying yeah
and to treat the performers the way the
club treats them which is like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] okay so five years ago helium opens
which is in a room but it was so
difficult to play I was there the first
six months it opened and I remember on
stage every time going oh I'm never
playing her again this is terrible but
then that's next time I came I gave it a
shot it was better and then over the
years you see and now it's a legitimate
amazing room it's a great club it first
of all the Portland I mean you it's one
of those cities where you want to move
there mm-hmm you know there's people
that look like you not in terms of
Asians but in terms of like history like
you know they can be where I am
yeah they can teach you about music and
bicycles is it very much like Silver
Lake yeah they have great Donuts like
hipstery Donuts where they put like pork
bits in Hazel that Mazal and a dried
blueberry basil from Blue Star
yeah so it's a city that should have
many a rooms ron funches from there and
not saying that lightly ron funches is a
black dude who's the future
he's funny very funny so you know but
you know that happened Saturday
[Music]